Let's talk to our caller from the eight five
zero area code eight five zero.
What's your name?
Where you calling from?
Oh, Hey David.
Hey, uh, my name is James.
I'm from middle of Network Florida.
Hey James.
What's going on?
Oh, wait a second.
James, are you on?
Are you from the Pensacola area?
Okay.
Hi.
Yeah.
Around there?
Okay.
I love that area.
Well, it's not, it's a small town near the
area.
It's not really big.
Okay.
Maybe, but Pensacola School [inaudible] no,
you wouldn't.
I have a question.
Okay.
Why aren't people marching through the streets
calling for Trump's impeachment?
I mean, right.
There's a lot that as American,
this is an easy one.
This is an easy one.
I, I, we, we dealt with this actually earlier
in the week.
Here's the reason why.
The system that benefits from people not marching
in the streets is the same system that people
from marching in the streets.
And what I mean by that is when you have stagnant
wages for the bottom 50% when you have some
people working two or three jobs, when you
have people who can't afford to miss a day
of work or who risk getting fired, if they
miss a day of work, they can't go march in
the streets.
And this is what perpetuates the system.
That makes sense.
Yeah, it's sad.
That makes a lot of sense.
It's an unfortunate bad.
Yeah.
I mean, but, but yeah, but you look at like
Hong Kong, Russia, Puerto Rico, uh, there's
like people like crowding the capitals, you
know, protesting.
No, there's not an America,
there's this interesting thing where I basically
tend to disagree with the, burn it all down
to build it back up.
Thing that some people agree with.
I, I'm okay with incrementalism in general,
but there is a reality that when things get
so bad that people don't even have a job to
cling to, then all of a sudden they might
be more ready to go march in the streets,
which is a sad reality.
Sometimes things have to get even worse so
that people no longer feel like there's any
downside to just bailing on whatever they're
doing and going to march in the streets.
We're not really there yet for the majority
of Americans because so many people, they're
hanging by a thread but they are hanging on
and
uh, that, that's just the dynamic that's inherent
to our system.
So it'll take something like another economic
crash.
It may for something like that to happen.
It May.
Yeah.
I don't know if that makes sense.
All right James, I appreciate the phone call.
I appreciate talking to you, man.
Have a good day.
Youtube.
Take care of a all right.